the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen only mode hey
good morning everybody it's Mike it's uh
middle of April April 14th already and
it's hard to believe that it's already
uh the middle of sorry of March not
April
um it's already the middle of March and
first quarter is pretty much already
done you know these markets lately have
been
pretty wild
um you know especially here in the U.S
with these potential bank failures and
you know getting bailed out and
what I want to be talking about today is
you know how to see some of these hidden
Market signs and opportunities in the
order flow because you know especially
yesterday with all the volatility in the
market you know people are thinking well
you know the Market's so crazy you know
it's so volatile it's hard to hard to
trade but you know what when you know
what to look for in the market
in the order flow it really
I don't say becomes easy but you know it
just becomes second nature that you can
see oh yeah it was a great opportunity
to sell here or to buy here so
what are we talking about today is is a
few things and you know as a former
professional Trader and you know
everyone says oh you know you know they
claim to be a professional Trader but
when I talk about being a professional
Trader I worked on an Institutional
trading desk uh for over 20 years and
I'm delighted to share with you the
strategies of order flow trading now
these strategies help experienced
Traders identify trends of the market
and capitalize on them while providing
beginners a way to safely conduct their
trading activities by understanding
what's really happening in the market
and it is essential for any Trader to
understand these strategies in order to
develop more successful trading results
because at the end of the day you know
we want to be more successful
successful in any Endeavor whether it's
trading
or you know whether it's playing a sport
right you always want to strive to to do
your best and today I'm going to teach
you uh several things one other show you
how to spot institutional Traders and
their activity
how to easily understand Market
sentiment especially you know when a
market like is moving around very fast
just like yesterday
um you know news is coming fast and it's
like a drinking out of a fire hose where
you know if you following Twitter or
heaven forbid you know watching CNBC
you know every couple minutes breaking
news something new is happening and the
markets are going up they're going down
they're going up and you know that's
where understanding Market sentiment but
more importantly spot where traders who
are driving the market are active and
ultimately your goal should be to make
better training Decisions by seeing how
the market is reacting
to the traders who are driving the
market or the market sentiment
or where the institutional Traders you
know are coming into the market right
now
so taking advantage of the hit
institutional order flow
can seem like a daunting process at
first and with a little focus and
dedication retail Traders such as
yourself and and even myself now you
know I lump myself in as a retail Trader
because you know I don't work as a
Trader at a bank or a trading firm
anymore
and you want to be able to tap into the
information that's available to us from
The Exchange
to use it to our advantage so by
studying order flow we can learn to
identify buying and selling patterns at
Big institutional investors leave behind
in the markets
so just really briefly you know that's
my picture anybody that's new to this
presentation or or who I am just give
you a little bit background now
I've got over 20 years of institutional
trading experience most recently
I spent eight years at JP Morgan in
Singapore on the trading desk okay prior
to that I worked for Cargill Cargill is
you know the big commodity Trading
Company here in the United States as
well as the world it's a privately held
company so not a lot of people know
about it but if you're in the trading
world you know about it I mean they
account for about
30 percent of grain exports and about 25
of meat exports but they're in
everything you know from oil to even
interest rates you know currency Futures
they trade everything
prior to that is with Commerce Bank the
big German Bank
um back when German banks were still uh
still relevant
um I spent four three and a half years
close to four years in Chicago uh
trading your ex out of Chicago SO
trading buns
um Dax shats Euro stocks and
I was the licensure X Trader where I had
I was literally one of only a handful of
Traders at the time that were trading
directly on on the urex electronic
trading terminal
directly into the exchange in the U.S I
mean when they first launched it
the cbot came out said hey you know this
is uh we can't have these foreign
exchanges in the US but fortunately I
got in so early that I was able to be
grandfathered in prior to that I spent
uh two years at EDF man the big English
Trading Company and prior to that was
with Dean Witter
um
I started on the CME trading floor and
eventually left the trading floor when
electronic trading was starting up so
you know the reason why I talk about my
background is because you know it's not
like oh you know I watched some YouTube
videos no I this is what I did and this
is what I teach right I teach you things
that helped me throughout my career
and you know I got started Electronics
trading when electronic trading first
started up you know this was back in the
the mid 90s trading on the native
exchanges
um from the CME which was Globex project
day which was on the Board of Trade
nimex access
um
which was you know the nymex and comex
system so you know what I talk about is
things that have helped me in my career
and it was a long career right I'm not
gonna you're not gonna last over 20
years
you know like professional trading firms
unless you're good at what you're doing
and you understand the markets and what
you're doing so you know that's why I
talk about my background up front so you
know it's coming from the horse's mouth
so I'm one of only a handful of former
institutional traders who have mastered
both order flow trading and teaching it
to retail Traders all over the world so
let's take a look at the steps that you
need to follow to
take advantage of the institutional
order flow that's traded in the market
every day
so get ready you know if you have a
phone you know just put it on silent or
turn it over so you're not distracted
um you know maybe get a pen and paper or
maybe take some notes
so a brief disclaimer now you know I do
want you to understand trading does
involve risk right you should only trade
with risk Capital that can you could
that's not going to jeopardize you know
your current lifestyle basically don't
trade with your rent money you know is
the simple way to say it or your
mortgage payment or your kids uh tuition
or or your lunch money so to speak
so just bear that in mind you know
trading is risky people do blow up
accounts left and right now I'm not
saying that you're going to do that with
order flow but you know you got to
understand the risks
um of anything before you get into it
you know if you play soccer you could
break your leg so
first thing I want to talk about is
spotting institutional Traders and their
activity now people don't really think
about it very much but it's not just
trading taking place there's different
types of trading that's taking place in
the market
there is aggressive Traders there are
passive Traders okay when people say
What's the difference you know people
buy people sell well someone who's going
to buy has to buy it from someone who's
selling just as someone who's selling
is going to sell to someone who's buying
but there's different types right you
have aggressive ones and you have
passive ones now what's the difference
Okay so
you know when you look at the market you
know you see a bid and an offer markets
five bit at six
the people that are trying to buy it at
five to pay five they're the passive
buyers the people that are trying to
sell it at six are the passive sellers
they provide liquidity in the market
right when people talk about you know no
liquidity in the market there's usually
when there's no bids or no offers
right on either side or both sides but
when there's a liquidity in the market
then you have people that are willing to
wait for the market to come to them now
the aggressive Traders right people say
you know I want to buy crude oil now
what's the market it's five bit at six
okay just buy it at six that is the
aggressive Trader the people that buy
whatever the market is
price is being offered or sell it at
whatever the current bid prices that is
the aggressive Traders they are the ones
that cross the bid offer
and either sell into the passive buyers
or sell into that liquidity or buy the
existing liquidity there now it's from
that different types of trading
that you get more information
and with order flow there's three sort
of cornerstones of
information there's Delta which is the
difference between the aggressive buyers
and the aggressive sellers so not only
do you have you know aggressive Traders
and passive Traders you also have
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
aggressive buyers are people that buy at
the market aggressive sellers or sellers
that sell at the market right they're
either buying the offer or they're
selling the bid
and the difference between them is
What's called the order flow Delta
so for example if you have a positive
Delta of
63 on a bar that tells you that in that
bar there was 63 more aggressive buyers
than aggressive sellers
just as if say the bar had minus 56
Delta then it'll tell you there's 56
more aggressive sellers than aggressive
buyers in the bar and it's from that
information that you can start to make
better trading decisions because now
you're looking at not only the volume
but how the volume is being transacted
now another
piece of information that you're going
to get from the order flow is What's
called the point of control
and if you're an intraday Trader you
know order flow is best used intraday
each bar that you're looking at whether
it's a one minute chart you know a
volume based chart a tick based chart
each bar has a point of control each bar
has a price level or the most volume
traded okay and that is Market generated
information it's going to tell you that
hey you know what at this price this was
sort of the fair price where everyone
was not everyone but the majority of
people were happy to transact
and then the last piece that's one of
the cornerstones is what's called
imbalances and imbalances also deal with
the aggressive Traders and it's when the
aggressive buyers outnumber the
aggressive sellers by a certain
percentage usually four to one you could
use whatever percentage you want but you
know it should be you know a reasonable
amount and think of a tug of war okay if
you have one person you know all people
being equal size one person against four
people well that's an imbalance the
people you know the four people on the
one side and the tug of war are
generally going to win
and it's the same in order flows but you
also have buying imbalances and selling
imbalances so buying a balance is when
the aggressive buyers outnumber the
aggressive sellers
by four to one or
a selling imbalances when you have you
know aggressive sellers outnumbering
aggressive buyers by four to one or more
so and it's from imbalances that you
could also
um determine you know who's really in
control of the market okay so those are
basically you know the sort of the
building blocks of order flow that you
know your analysis will grow from now
this is yesterday in the e-minis this is
a simple one minute chart you know a
common chart and most people would look
at this chart and say Ah that's nothing
you know Mark is just sort of going
sideways uh it's just noise right
there's no trading opportunity well
there is and if you know what to look
for in the order flow
because you know order flow Traders will
look at this
and they'll see that hey you know what
there actually is very good opportunity
here because they know what to look for
you know in the market all right and I'm
going to teach you how to look at a
chart like this and see that information
very easily
and you know when you're looking at a
simple bar chart right a Candlestick
chart people don't really look at bar
charts they focus more on Candlestick
charts
it's really one-dimensional you're
price points are basically the open the
high the low the close and you're
looking at the relationship to the open
to the close
um you know there's really not a whole
lot of other information you could use
and I understand you know people like to
look at Price patterns you know in the
Candlestick charts okay fine you know
they work they work sometimes they
oftentimes they fail more often than not
now when you add a point an order flow
chart this is your simple order flow
chart from
several years ago I mean a decade ago
where really all you had to go off of
was you know your Delta
component control your imbalances and
that was about it right and it was good
right you know a lot of people made a
lot of money trading order flow just
based off those pieces of information
but you could actually do further deeper
analysis
and more importantly that analysis could
be put into
your chart
so instead of sitting here trying to
think oh is it what's happening down
here
or you know or you know why did the
market come back here and then then move
up well if you have software that
is programmed to read the order flow it
will tell you
it'll tell you what's happening right
this is right Market was coming down
remember this was our
this was the move right we were selling
off the market started rallying back up
pulled back a little bit continued to
Rally
right wouldn't you like to know that hey
you know what maybe you know if the
market pulls back here it could stop
here right and then continue its move or
maybe this is going to be the low
that market is rejecting sort of these
these lower prices down here at 107.
you know 66.
you know because people you know that
like to look at candlesticks oh there's
a bullish pattern here there's a bullish
pattern here well it didn't work you
know this bullish pattern did so
yeah sometimes you need a little bit
more information and the order flow
provides it to you
and the order flow software nowadays has
that capability to tell you hey you know
what as this Market was selling down
the market was getting weaker the
aggressive selling rather was getting
weaker so you had the aggressive selling
coming down and it was just it was
weakening so I was telling you you know
once you know that that's selling as
you're coming down into these lows down
in here
is getting weak then you could position
yourself
to take advantage of the move back up
because if the selling is getting weak
chances are it's not going to continue
going lower
right because the aggressive sellers the
people that are moving that market are
no longer there
and this is just one of the tools that's
available in the order flow right that
you could have you know that software
exists
to show you this plain as day right it's
very simple to see that hey you know
what there's that weakness here right
imagine right if you're looking at your
bar chart you're sitting here wondering
uh maybe this Market's going to Rally
here off this off you know bounce up
here you know it goes up to green one
green bar then it sells off again
well what made this low
a better buy than this one well it's
because as this Market was coming down
that aggressive selling right the that
was moving the market lower was
weakening
and once you know that the aggressive
selling in the direction is weakening
well you remove that pressure on the
market from going down naturally it
should just start going up
now Market sentiment right Market
sentiment is is important
because it's the attitude
you know an opinion of
the market expressed in price
and it's it's the sentiment that
suggests direct directions of prices
I mean think about it for a second right
I mean we all have our opinion of the
market
and that's what drives a lot of people
to take a position so generally Market
Stedman is divided into two categories
bullish
or bearish positive or negative
now keep in mind that trading decisions
should not depend solely on Market
sentiment as it changes as rapidly
depending on current events and you know
yesterday was a great example
all that extra volatility in the market
because of those bank failures
is affecting Market sentiment and add to
that you know we're living in an
information age where
information just comes fast and furious
you know whether you're on social media
or watching TV
we're searching the internet
you're seeing so much information come
through that
you know you're going to miss trades
like this
excuse me
it doesn't look like much but this is a
10 point move it's a 500 move from here
to here
and what it was it was weakness just
like on the other chart that I showed
you with the euro currency
this Market had been going up now it's
exhibiting weakness right the order flow
is getting weaker as this Market is
moving and you have a quick you know in
two minutes a quick 10 point move
basically
from here
to here
and it doesn't matter which Market
you're looking at you know
order flow transfers itself neatly to
other markets because really at the end
of the day all order flow is is the it's
the market
you're anticipating what's happening
based off of the information generated
from the market this is Japanese Yen
yesterday
right it came up here to this double top
and then sold off
why because there was weakness up here
sorry
and if you know that you're coming up to
a double top but the aggressive buying
is weakening what do you think is going
to happen you think we're still going to
go higher no
because you're removing that buying
pressure or not I say removing it but
the buying pressure is dying off and at
aggressive buying
that once the market starts turning
around
and look for it to sell off
right now bonds right this is again this
is a one minute chart now we're up here
near the high of the day anytime you're
up near a high of the day or down near a
low of the day
you always want to be asking can this
Market go higher
or is it going to sell off just like
here yes you know on the swing high in
the end
it's coming back up to you know this
double top can this Market go higher
we don't know well if you read the order
flow you can see that that aggressive
buying that buying that's going to take
the market higher is getting weaker
chances are it's not going to but
yesterday in the bonds this was around 7
30.
right this green line here is the high
of the day we had just hit the high of
the day we hit it once twice three times
sort of come off okay well uh you know
people are looking at this and saying
well this is it Market's probably going
to start to sell off because we can't
you know we've already tested that high
basically twice and it's starting to
come off from the high but then you see
what happens it reverses and takes out
the high and goes higher well
if you're reading the order flow you can
see that yeah you have some aggressive
selling coming in but it's getting
weaker
and if the market is trying to sell off
but that aggressive selling that's going
to cause the market to sell off is
getting weaker
it's probably not going to sell off and
it doesn't
right it just it stops right here
reverses and starts going higher again
and that's you know a simple tool in
order flow right gold
okay again Market was selling off quite
nicely quite sharply we all went from
1917 down to 1913 in about five six
minutes oh you know the Gold's going
lower well it's it's not right you see
how it just stopped here
and even came back right to that level
is because
that aggressive selling is getting
weaker now
you know in the past you'd have to
understand what's happening you know in
the order flow and price and all that to
understand that it's getting weaker now
with software it could just it'll just
highlight it to you simple oh there's
weakness here just says there's there's
weakness here
so you're no one at these prices 19 you
know around 1913 19 13 and a half
there's weakness down here right
aggressive sellers don't really want to
sell down here if once you know that
information
it's gonna make
you know your trading decision a bit
easier because you know you shouldn't be
looking for shorts you should be looking
for reasons to potentially be getting
long
crude oil crude oil is all over the
market yesterday you know it was like
four bucks up for I say like four
dollars down
um but you can see in here right as it's
just sort of humming around the 7450
area weakness weakness weakness right
because people don't want to keep
selling it down you know below 74.50
they're giving up below selling it below
74.50 now the thing that's interesting
it's not like there was a lot of big
liquidity down here where you know
there's a big buyer sitting down here
absorbing everything you see as it's
coming down you see the volumes that's
trading you know 20 to
36 you know 22 4 so it's not like
there's a big buyer here that that's bid
for 500 contracts it's just taking
everything in
people they're testing the market right
they're testing it to go lower they
trade six Lots today they trade two lots
they trade two lots but nobody's got the
appetite to sell it lower and what
happens the market reverses and you know
it has this nice reversal from about
74.50 you get that one bar that's you
know almost a 50 Cent move in that one
bar
and it just keeps going up
so again you know understanding what's
happening in the order flows is just
going to put you slightly ahead of
everybody else that's just looking at
price because they're thinking oh this
is it you know we keep testing this low
we're going to break out well you know
that chances are we're not going to
break out because that's selling that
you're looking for to move the market
down
is too weak it's not enough to move the
market down
you know Traders love to talk about how
volume is important and it is I mean
volume is important but was just as
important is the type of volume the
aggressiveness of trading or in the case
I just showed you the decrease in
directional aggressive trading which is
a sign that sentiment is changing so
think about it
okay there's volume but there's
different types of volume there's
aggressive volume and there's passive
volume
and you're not just looking you know a
lot of Traders spend all their time
looking for volume but really
where you're going to get an edge
especially if you're using order flow
and that's what trading is all about is
finding an edge here and there
is finding where there's lack of volume
lack of aggressive trading because
ultimately that's what really drives the
market is the aggressive trading you
know if people don't keep buying it
higher higher and higher prices the
Market's not going to keep going up just
as if they're not aggressively selling
into lower prices taking it out selling
it at the next lower price and so on
the Market's not going to keep going
down so if you can tell that that
aggressive buying or that aggressive
selling
is slowing down
getting lesser and lesser
that's going to give you an edge over
people that are just following price
now
being able to spot traders who are
driving the market you know today with
CPI and the market again went nuts
um if you have you guys are on Twitter
but you know I remember last week Biden
was saying that um
CPI is not going to be that bad and lo
and behold
um it wasn't but I don't know six
percent is still six percent it's not
like uh last year six percent was a big
problem this year they think six
percent's not
um so
you know there's always things that
drive the market so
one of the things that is very important
is having a way to determine when a big
Trader has a big order that he has to
get done it doesn't care too much about
his effect on price you know because
ultimately you know when you're a size
Trader
yeah you've got an order for 500
contracts 750 a thousand whatever
um there's times where
it's going to have an impact on the
market right and if you're trying to
trade that type of size
you don't want to impact the market
because once people start picking up
that oh you know this guy's got a big
order to do they're going to jump in
front of you
all right and ultimately you're going to
get a worse fill and people think oh you
know what you know whatever it's that
doesn't matter well it does matter
because there's a thing called execution
Alpha
and what execution Alpha is is you know
it's basically a gauge of how good
you're executing the trade
and
you know when you're trading ones and
two lots it's not that big a deal but
when you're a size Trader and you're
trading you know 500 Lots thousand Lots
one tick right one tick in the in the
e-minis twelve and a half dollars
on a thousand lot is is twelve and a
half thousand dollars right if imagine
if you're consistently
chasing the market getting lousy fills
you know even just a half a tick on a
thousand that's six thousand dollars and
that's you know on one trade
you're trading in a bunch of different
markets
each day at the end of the year it's a
lot of money so you know they're very
um conscious of how well they're
executing their trades you know that's
why now big banks are spending tons of
money into
finding easier you know better ways to
execute larger orders
but there's times where you know big
Traders I just need to get this done and
I don't really care that much because
one either I'm hemorrhaging money just
kept me out or two I think the market is
going to move so just get me in right
now okay
and think of it as as Market forces now
you know when someone's looking at a
chart this is a Candlestick chart or
sorry a footprint chart but if you're
looking at Candlestick chart you're not
even going to see the volumes at price
but when you're looking at a footprint
chart
there's that information in there okay
and you know what the volume is traded
on the bid the volume is traded on the
offer and you know one of the things
that we've discovered with order flow
is you can often see it's what we call
sequencing when a big order is working
its way through the market and again
software is
a great tool to have to help your
Trading
all right
if you could tell the software hey
highlight to me where those where
there's like potentially a big order
working its way through the market you
know if it's a buy order or highlighted
as blue if it's a cell highlighted as
you know magenta you want to make
everything green and red
but you could just see here big order
potentially going through the market big
order going through the market buys buys
big sells big sells big buy big buy big
buy big buy big buy big sell
right and it's that information that's
going to help you
position yourself instead of swimming
against the stream so to speak trade in
the direction of that big money that's
being traded you know
if you could spot that there's hey
there's big selling going on in here
you don't want to be getting long get
long for what to get run over
all right if this Market is selling off
and it's a big buying coming in here and
you're trying to get short well again
it's just you're standing in front of a
freight train you can get run over
trying to short here you're going to get
run over try and short anywhere in here
you're gonna get run over
so knowing where these areas are one you
know it could give you a trading
opportunity but two
it's going to help identify that hey you
know I don't want to be trading in that
direction right I don't want to be
trading short when I know that there's
big orders going through and on a day
like yesterday where
nobody really knows what's going on with
the fed and you know they're doing with
these bank bailouts
big Traders
they're just coming into the market
balancing their books balancing their
position they're not so price sensitive
at a time like this because it is I
don't say a chaotic time but it's it's a
sort of a fast moving market and they
don't want to be missing out on anything
because while you know people look at
these bars and think Ah that's nothing
it's actually you know these bars are
you know 10 points and 10 points in the
S PS is a 500 move so
you know when someone when
that sort of volatility like that picks
up
um you know the uncertainty in the
market big Traders have a tendency to
just try and get everything done as
quickly and effectively as possible
euro currency same thing again you know
the same Concepts whether you're looking
at
e-minis or NASDAQ or your currency bonds
it
it still it carries over it can be
applied to pretty much any Market as
long as you know it's an auction Market
but if you know that there's big sellers
in here
you probably don't want to be getting
long just as if you know there's big
buyers in here you don't want to be
getting short and instead you could also
be looking for reasons to get long or
reasons to get short right when you know
that yeah there's a big seller was
present up here and if we start breaking
off you could get short just as you know
there's a big buyer in here in here it's
your reason to potentially be getting
long as well
bonds
right right here in the middle right
we're selling off we pull back a little
bit up
and then the big seller comes in and the
market continues down
right and again you know once you start
putting these tools pieces of
information that you're seeing in the
order flow together with your knowledge
of trading right because not every time
you get a bounce
you want to get short right maybe you
would want to get long and I know some
people say oh the Market's bouncing
we're coming to go back up well if you
know that there's a big order going
through the market right what we call
sequencing
you're not going to get long
you're not going to fight it and
instead you're probably going to look at
it from the opposite say okay Mark is
selling off he got a little bit of a
bounce now that strong sign there's a
big order coming through the market it's
time to get short all right to catch
those moves gold
okay see it big order going through the
market here rallies all the way up to
this High big order coming up in here 19
you know this is a move from 1905 up to
1912. back down to 1909 all right we got
some more aggressive selling
crude oil
came right down
you know a nice 45 degree move down
it starts reversing it's almost a
v-shaped reversal but after we hit that
low it's enough to attract buyers coming
into that market
to help move the market back up
okay so that's that's order flow
sequencing again it's information based
off of what's trading in the market
understanding where the big orders are
coming into the market that are
affecting the direction of the market
right you always want to be trading
ideally in the direction
of the big money right the people that
are moving the market so to speak don't
fight them
play with them right if you think of it
as like
you know basketball right if you want to
um play with Michael Jordan
or play against him right if you were in
the league during you know when Michael
Jordan was you know at his Prime and
you're on the same team well you're
going to the championship every year if
you're playing against them you're not
going to go anywhere so think of it like
that and in trading
you know you you want to be trading on
the side of the mark of the money that
is influencing the market that's causing
the market to move
now
make better trading Decisions by seeing
how the market is reacting right and
this is where order flow is going to
come in and really help you you know I I
just got to chuckle when I see people
post stuff on Facebook or whatever you
know Twitter say oh I had a bad day I'm
just going to take my best setups well
you should always be taking your best
setups for one or you shouldn't be
taking marginal setups I mean you
shouldn't really be trading unless your
setups are the best ones that you could
take so
I mean I never really understood that
concept of well I'll just take a good
setup no you should always be taking
your best setups
and as a Trader right this is something
that goes way back for me
I've always wanted to understand why a
market comes back to a level and then
reverses
right why does the market come back you
know Market was shot up came right back
to this level went back up stopped here
and it came back down went back up
stopped here why
there must be a reason well there is
okay and it deals with the value you
know perceived value of the market
right you can see here right this is
what we call this is the value area
every bar right I talked to you about
earlier about every bar having a value a
point of control right the area of
um volume the most volume in a bar
now value area takes it a step further
if you've ever studied Market profile or
auction Market Theory you understand
what the value area is value area you
know on a profile is where 70 percent of
the volume trades for the day but you
can actually take it and you could
customize it to whatever time frame you
want or volume range or tick range and
by understanding where that volume is
concentrated on it gives you an idea of
or value is where people perceive value
to be in the market and that's why the
markets come back to a certain level
here or here or here
okay
so again value areas where seventy
percent of volume traded for a defined
period now most Traders
in the past defined it for a day right
on on The Daily Market profile but you
could Define it for a shorter time
period or even custom periods based not
only on time but you know volume or
ticks even
this is zero currency it's a five minute
Euro currency chart yesterday you'll
notice it would come up we hit the high
start coming off stops right here goes
back up makes a new high starts coming
off stops right here
well why
that's because that's where this value
area was forming now where it gets more
interesting is
you can see that this value is
developing over time it's not just this
one bar but you have another one another
one another one another one another one
another one another one
this was the area where Traders found a
lot of value
market maintenance new high up here
starts coming off you can see it came
right back to the tick here to the tick
here and continue down
so five minute chart now this is on
tenure notes
Market
sold off went back up right to that area
came back off right to this area again
right I mean it's it's
the way I describe it is like getting
the beans from the guy that sold Jack is
Beanstalk beans right by understanding
that hey you know what I have an area
here right I could have the software
projected for me on a chart tell me that
if we come back up here we could
probably come off or if we come back
down here we could probably rally
wheat this is a tick based chart 250
ticks
foreign
level here I got a level here a level
here Market came back to this level by
attack Market came back to this level
Market came back here
popped up a little bit went sideways and
sold off then I got a level here we're
staying below the level coming right
back within one tick of this level
right this is
the best Market generated information
that you could have because it's not
based on price itself right I mean
people talk about Bollinger Bands macd
RSI
you know EMAs everything you know they
all everyone's got all these different
indicators that are based off of price
only right or some derivation of price
but when you start
making tools based on the order flow
you're basing tools off of the market
right order flow is the market you know
I always laugh I see people sometimes
posting charts up oh yeah I'm using this
Bollinger band 20 Bollinger band with a
21 EMA well it's basically the same
thing right you got to start looking at
the Market's information how it's
trading this was today after CPI you
know the CPI number came out very wacky
um price action afterwards
but you can see right I got a level here
right value
that was forming here value that's
forming here what's this Market do well
it's trading in this range between the
upper value and the lower value that's
what you expect to see
when you're looking at Value right you
expect the market to be trading within
that value the value to hold just as you
saw you know on the wheat Market on the
10 years on the euro currency
you know and on the on the e-minis right
markets love to trade around value they
love to establish value because that's
ultimately that's what the markets were
created for right the transfer risk and
where do people want to transfer risk at
areas that they perceive value at so
when a market comes back to existing
value you know that had just been
created it often reacts to that
so I've covered a lot
in the last 40 minutes or so and
hopefully by now you you know some of
the ins and outs of order flow and how
to make smarter trading decisions
unfortunately I can't cover everything
in a quick training session like this
but there's much more to learn about
order flow training and I hope that you
now have a good understanding of order
flow Basics right go from the I can't do
it mindset to the I can do it mindset
you know and I I've worked with a lot of
retail Traders over the years since I
left JPMorgan and
the ones that I find that do the best
are the ones that that want to learn the
ones that
will be see the market as a question and
try to answer it right if they get stuck
on something they'll try and figure it
out they don't rely on people the the
spoon feed them right because at the end
of the day you got to be motivated
yourself
because trading can be a daunting
experience for many but with the right
set of knowledge and strategies you can
learn how to trade order flow and when
you join orderflows.com it was a company
that I started after leaving JPMorgan I
share with you my most valuable trading
experiences to guide you and make sure
your efforts are optimally rewarded so
I've got something special for you it's
the order flows Trader software the
software that you saw used in this
presentation
okay now
I created this software because the
software that was out there
was just basic right I mean it was good
it was a simple footprint chart but I
needed something because I know that the
software can't do analysis for you and
when I release the software years ago in
2015 there were four tools now there's
like 18 17 or 18 order flow tools on
there to help you understand I've talked
about a few today I talked about the
value areas
we've talked about sequencing right I've
talked about Market weakness I've talked
about
what was the other one
um
yeah I can't remember it now but
you could see that that is the software
doing that analysis for me to make my
trading a lot easier rather than sit
there trying to pick out what's
happening in the order flow oh is this
happening or that happening no like
program it into a software to show me
what is taking place
so if you want to get started go to
orderflows.com
oft6 okay it's and really what it's like
okay it's like taking
everything that I've learned
about trading with the order flow and
putting it into your software so it's
like having get inside my mind
as I have in me sitting on
behind you or next to you when you're
trading tapping you on the shoulder
saying hey you know what this is taking
place in the market or this is taking
place you know or you know there's
weakness here or there's strength here
take advantage of it okay
foreign
and and really it's it's something that
I started years ago it started to be
implemented by a lot of other softwares
but you know yeah you could get other
order flow software but it's not they're
not the ones that created the tools
right and as a result
they don't have the education that goes
with it right because you know if you've
ever felt like you're struggling to
understand something only to have it
click in place and become easier That's
The Power of understanding how something
works and take trading for example if
you don't understand how the market
works and what makes the markets move
it's going to be very confusing and
frustrating and the big mistake Traders
make is thinking that having the right
software is all they need to be
successful in trading but it could be
further from the truth right so if you
don't know how to use this software it's
not going to do you any good
right I mean it's one thing to have
software that tells you hey this is
happening that's but you got to know how
to trade it right that's why I focus on
providing education on how to trade with
order flow because I want you know my
students to be successful and I know
that starts with giving them the tools
they need to understand the market but
once you have a solid foundation you
begin to place trades with confidence
and that's when the real success starts
to happen so to help you on your trading
Journey right not only are you getting
software but you're getting an education
you get access to my order flow trading
course
for free normally I sell it for 297 you
can go to my website now and buy it for
297. I'm including that for free but not
only that I'm going to give you access
to 56 more videos
from my inner circle video series right
this was a series of videos that I did
on a lot of different little nuances in
the market right in the order flow so
that you know what to look for right and
you can understand what's happening in
the market and when you add all that up
right the software normally sells for
900 training 297. the Inner Circle video
series is is another close to 500 and to
be honest you can't even buy the Inner
Circle video series
at all right it's only available as part
of this promotion you know that's
already a total of almost Seventeen
hundred dollars now
it's one thing to learn from videos and
books right I mean but you got to be
disciplined
and you got to make a commitment say
okay I'm going to study one hour every
day and it's hard for a lot of people
because life gets in the way and what I
found to be very helpful for Traders is
live training where you can ask
questions to me right as for the last
three years I've been hosting live user
training sessions that are open to all
users of our software where I drive home
what I saw on the order flow for the
past week and you can ask your questions
about areas you may be struggling with
your analysis or understanding the
markets and if you can't attend you
could watch the replay we've got over
195 episodes there right that you could
watch and
it kills me because I see people selling
software then they want you to pay extra
to learn how to use it to learn what
you're looking at what's the what's the
point right you're already making an
investment in the software that should
be included in it right people charge
200 and up a month for that and you know
I have people been in my sessions since
I started doing them several years ago
right they still attend them they still
watch them
now what I discussed today is just a
small sample of the kinds of analysis
that I talk about on a weekly basis in
the live training and it's every
Tuesdays at 7 pm and tonight's one of
those nights
now I go into much more detail of of
trading with
order flow and again you know sometimes
you got a question you're stuck with
something I don't understand or you know
maybe you want me to take a look at a
market and see how my analysis compared
to yours you know that's what the whole
point of these weekly sessions are is to
give you access to me
that you know is is something that
um you know other software just don't
provide because they just want to sell
software they just copy indicators or
tools and put it out there for a lower
price but they don't they don't give you
that access
now as a special bonus for those of you
from investors Expo they'll give you
also a trading course that I provide
it's called the order flow Playbook okay
and there's
like eight or nine modules in here but
there's 10 additional order flow trade
setups that you will learn so not only
again will you get software but you're
going to get
trade setups explained to you so you
know what to look for when you're
looking at the market normally sell this
for 297 you're gonna get it for free
so when you add in the price of the
software it's 8.99 the trading course
297.
Inner Circle video series 497 the weekly
Group Training minimum of 200 a month or
flows Playbook
valued at 297 and these are prices that
I sell this stuff at
you buy it separately it's going to cost
you
21.90 2190 but you're not going to pay
that it's just a one-time payment of
7.49.
so just go to
orderflows.com6.html I put the link in
the chat there's no more recurring
payments or any other payments in the
future you know or I've seen you know I
I know I've bought software where it's
like
they keep getting rebuild rebuild every
month or every six months or every year
and it's like you can't cancel it you
know it's like you try to cancel it and
you think it's canceled then you get
another charge you dispute it you lose
or you can even cancel your your card
and you still get charged on it you know
I I hate that that's why it's just a
one-time payment there's no recurring
payments or charges that you're going to
get in the future and
yeah that's important to me because
you know I I don't like that and and I'm
sure nobody else likes that now you will
need to pay your data fees and and ninja
Trader fees my software runs on
ninjatrader 8.
okay so
um obviously you can't get past paying
data fees because you do need a
real-time data you just need level one
data you don't need level two data level
one is is all you need
so to get started go to orderflows.com
slash aft6.html takes you to this page
just scroll down the page on the side
now there's you know a bunch of videos
there's an explanation of all the tools
that you're getting
and you can see down here it's going to
take you to this button it says click
here to buy you're going to get the
order flows Trader software you get
access to the Overflow trading course
the Inner Circle video series The Weekly
live group trainings the order flow
Playbook trading course now Grant you
know keep in mind it will take a
um some time to get these set up because
you have to manually go in and create
login user IDs for the trading courses
and things like that so you know just
give it uh just give it a little bit
I'll give it some in an hour or two
while your order is being processed and
everything else is being generated
so it's just 7.49 and it takes you to
PayPal PayPal processes your payment I
don't get your credit card I don't want
your credit card information I got
enough stuff to deal with
um
and then you just go through there right
so to get started go to orderflows.com
oft6.html
and you know it's a special bonus if
you've made it through the end here
I wrote a book on order flow trading
okay it's called trading order flow and
this was
um
originally the plan was for me to write
this book not to create any software but
then you know when I was creating soft
you know when I was creating the book I
was like gosh you know this is how the
software got
developed as I was writing my book and
I'm like gosh it'd be so much nicer if
these tools you know things were put
into the software
and that's how the software was
developed as as a result of this book
now you're not going to get the an
actual hardcover copy you're just going
to get a digital download so go to
orderflows.com
book.html I also put the link in the
chat
you're gonna have to enter your name and
email address hit submit
and it'll take you to the download page
okay so again to get started just go to
orderflows.com oft6.html
and I hope to see you guys on the inside
okay oh you know I got a little bit of
time here I'll take a look at one or two
questions
um Trader says I love your YouTube you
know I was
creating some YouTube videos earlier
this year I I had to stop for some
personal reasons but I am going to be
starting up again
um I I did get sick
um earlier late last month early this
month so I've really been not feeling
well so that also hindered me posting
new videos
so
you know a question I get a lot is will
this work with Forex well yes it will
work with Forex but I do recommend if
you're trading Forex to seriously
consider looking at the CME currency
contracts
because there's a big difference with
data data that comes from Forex Brokers
come from that particular broker which
is usually a white label from a bank you
know it could be JP Morgan it could be
Barclays or B of A
um and you're trading against their book
whereas Futures markets are traded
um through a centralized exchange and
the bid and the offer that you see it's
what everybody sees every trade that
goes through is what you see as well
whereas with Forex it could be think of
it as a trading pit something could be
trading on one side of the pit but not
trading on the other
okay and that could be a problem when it
comes to data because your data feed
can be different than the data you're
getting from your
um
from your broker
okay and lastly what platform does the
software run on it well runs on
ninjatrader 8 okay ninja Trader it's for
retail Traders it's a good platform
you know you don't need a fancy
um let's say computer or whatever you
know software run on an i5 an i7
um you know but you do you do need you
know a relatively recent computers you
know sometimes people haven't upgraded
their computers for 10 years you know
anytime you're trading right you got
money on the line you know you want to
use something decent so if you're going
to be Trading you know stick with some
good a good trading platform and I found
ninjatrader to be reliable
so on that note everybody I'll end it
there for this presentation again thanks
for taking the time out and catching
this presentation and if you got any
questions uh just let me know right my
email is just Mike at orderflows.com
so have a great rest of your day and
I'll catch you guys later bye bye
foreign